kim and pete davidson just made it
official yep
instagram official that is oh my god on
friday the 41 year old kkw beauty
founder posted a series of snaps to
instagram including this one and this
one featuring the 28 year old comedian
that's kim and pete laying on the floor
puckering up
and that that's the reality star posing
for a selfie with her man serving up
some serious kissy face i love that and
from the caption it seems pete is kim's
ride or die quote whose car are we gonna
take a reference to this scene between
ben affleck and jeremy renner in the
town
i need your help
i can't tell you what it is you can
never ask me about it later and we're
going to hurt some people
who's kyle we're going to take
after the skims founder shared the
loved-up pics her inner circle was quick
to chime in her sister chloe writing i
love this
her makeup artist ash k holm gushing you
guys are too cute while her bestie simon
huck screamed
there he is
i love that energy in my life of course
kim and pete first started dating in
october after she hosted saturday night
live i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not i sure
am jasmine
since then the two have been spotted
together in each other's hometowns new
york and la as well as on getaways to
palm springs and the bahamas it's really
lit and fun and crazy a source recently
told et that the two have gotten even
closer and the king of staten island
star has been going out of his way to
connect with kim's crew in fact when et
chatted with jonathan chebin one of
kim's besties last month he weighed in
on their love i think it's cool you know
what she's having fun i guess you know
uh you know i i've hung out with them a
couple of times and
you know i love her to death so whatever
whatever makes her happy so will we get
to see more of pete on the kardashians
new hulu series during a recent
interview with variety the makeup mogul
said they haven't filmed together yet
but she's not opposed to it
you just gotta roll with it she adds
that filming a reality show it's just
not what he does but if they were at an
event together he wouldn't tell the
cameras to get away don't worry though
because the beauty mogul teases that she
will share all the juicy details on the
new show like how they met and how it
all went down quote i'm definitely open
to talking and i definitely explain it
[Music]
you